well I think the interesting phenomena
about this job is that if you're very
lucky and if you play it right you can
go on doing it all your life more or
less because in most jobs you get to the
age I am now and you're asked to retire
to go off and do something else play
golf or whatever but if you're an actor
your usefulness carries over I mean
roles change obviously and so there's
always something the doors closes on
some things and they open on others
which is you know very reassuring the
process is it's it's odd it's like mr.
micawber you always hope that something
will turn up
as much as you expect to plan it you
can't because in a way you're dependent
on you know other people's employment
unless you are a lot of actors on I've
done it myself you become very proactive
and you create opportunities for
yourself which is more often easier said
than done
you know I have a terrible facility to
say yes to everything including doing
and doing this interview you know yeah
another leap into the unknown
but it leads you into sometimes into a
lot of trouble but more often than not
into a whole new interesting you know
sphere and the invitation I was in fact
was of the Aspen ideas festival where
somehow I don't know how I
I dunno how I got there I was very happy
to be part of this extraordinary you
know week of of intellectual discussion
and with people who you know really the
movers and shakers and just to be a fly
on the wall was wonderful and you know I
also got to do something there so you
know it the performer I think I always
try to look back to the you know the
days the Elizabeth
days where a performer was expected to
be not only a dynamic actor and also a
great speaker this is another thing
that's fallen by the wayside the actual
physical act of acting and voice
production is all you know come by the
board because we all now rely on little
microphones and we we mumble but he was
also expected to be playwright musician
dancer whatever you know we're all now
we're all put in our little pigeon holes
you're even a stage actor rather than a
theatre actor it's it's it's um it's
very depressing whereas you know the
Renaissance feeling was that you were
capable of anything you put your mind to
well obviously entertainment is
important and as we have more and more
leisure time it becomes increasingly
important and I think that's where not
just mindless entertainment we know
filling up the hours I think it does
become important to you know to to have
entertainment that really increases you
know what a piece of work is man again
that sounds pretentious but I do think
there is you know we inhale we if we
speak English when herod an
extraordinary culture and it has to be
handed down and my only concern is that
you know when there are cats in the
schools
it's the performing arts education that
often goes by the board which is very
short-sighted I know that you know
obviously athletics is very important
the exercise of the physical body but
the exercise of the imagination
I think is equally vital and it's a very
well-known fact that that if you have a
performing arts program it often it
leads to great success in you know other
academic subjects there's a there's a
you know synergy between the
you